with siberia
this is a movie to me that feels stuffed
with a lot of different ideas and images
and surrealness and i'm curious what was
the first
image or idea that kind of sparked you
to want to make this movie
i might think it was the uh snow you
know
that kind of cabin in the middle of
nowhere
you know kind of a bar you know i mean
it but it's it's not like he's living in
a house away from everything he's got
like a business
you know he's running a bar only it's in
the middle of nowhere
so what is it about like
being isolated in the middle of nowhere
that was inspiring to you
you know these ideas just come you know
what i mean i'm not like you know
just like we had finished vaseline and i
was just like
you know when that there's that period
where
you're writing you know i mean or you've
got to put something down
you know or you finished one thing and
now
it's you know it's not something i was
thinking of for a long time it's just
something that kind of
just came to me you know the idea of two
guys there and
they might not might not beat two
different people you know but there's
a guy in some way he thinks someone else
is there
that was kind of the beginning yeah uh
and this is a return a reunion with you
and willem dafoe and i'm curious what is
your working relationship like what are
the two of you bring out of each other
you know i like to think we bring the
best out of each other
you know i mean we've been doing this
for a while we started i think um
you know new roads i don't know that was
probably 98
you know i mean we had known each other
and um before
but um you know with him when we do a
film
it leads to another film you know when
we work in a certain way
it it it brings us to the next you know
place to go you know
and um you know it's not like we never
kind of resolve it it's always like
open-ended
and yeah whether it's we're feeling we
there's something more we could do
something better we could do we could
you know but it's always a
step in the in into the future with him
since you've been working together for
so long
and since things feel kind of unresolved
do you feel like that leads to
kind of frank conversations that the two
of you can have that maybe you couldn't
with
a newer actor you're working with you
know we're bros you know i mean yeah
we've been friends a long time so
um you know the director active
relationship you've got to get
you got to get right to the you got to
get it right to the high point
of communication even if it's somebody
you never work with
you know i mean that's part of my gig if
somebody i work with
maybe for three hours in the afternoon
you know i got to get right
to the prime place
you know for us now it's maintaining
that
throughout you know the years that we've
been together
talking but it's you know but you know
with him he travels he goes here we both
do other things you know so we're coming
back together
both with his experience bringing you
know all his new
experiences in our mind you know and
then you know
anybody else we're changing constantly
so
you know it's never like i'm working
with the same guy
yeah you're always changing um right you
brought up kind of the
the ambiguity of whether or not these
are two people in this cave or
just ambiguity in general about this
movie did you speak with willem or
anyone else making it
about quote-unquote what is true versus
like what is a dream
is that important to you when you were
making this yeah for sure you know i
mean you got to get everybody on the
same page you know you could you could
be
you know when you're sitting alone in
front of a computer
you could be as oblique and surreal as
you want
but you know when you bring in like uh a
shitload of people and in this situation
you got people you know we're doing this
film in three different languages
you know i mean four different you know
we shot in mexico in germany
you know we shot in the italian that's
three languages right there
then you got english then you got my
english so now you have five languages
you did so you know you gotta yeah we
battle all those conversations
and then you got willa playing the
different roles so you know
it's not like when you know when you're
finally shooting now you you turn it
into a
into you know 3d reality
you know do you care about after you
kind of turn this into a
a concrete experience do you kind of
care about it that's a good word yes
that's the word hey it's yours take it
no
you took it again all right do you care
please please do you care about what an
audience's interpretation
after that or once you make it is it
just kind of like
whatever an audience wants to do with it
is their business well and that's going
to be the case no matter what i mean
do i you know am i concerned about how
people react to the movie for sure you
know
i mean we're putting it out there for
people to watch i mean the film don't
really exist outside
you know until there are people watching
it
and then expressing it and then you know
in the interaction between um
you know the audi when they can be you
know
between the audience and the filmmakers
so sure i'm
um you know i'm all ears somebody
sincere
and you know wants to be as
you know generous and and and positive
as we are giving it to them
they want to respond i'm into it you
know you know somebody wants to get
cynical
or negative i'm not so up to it you know
that makes sense to me this must have
been an
interesting film to try and have an
audience relationship
with given the timing of its release
kind of during
pandemic lockdown stuff to the point
where you made a documentary
about being caught in lockdown what did
what did working on this film in
releasing this film
how did that help you reckon with or
deal with lockdown and the pandemic
you know i mean you don't want to be
psychic about [ __ ] but um
you know this is a perfect lockdown kind
of you think it was made after
yeah yeah but it was like two years
before so
you know again it's brought just some
kind of crazy zeitgeist going on here
um yeah you know we made the film
we had an opportunity to do a
documentary
on the on the um when we brought the
film to siberia i mean just
to uh berlin not so great berlin
although we did bring it to siberia
um when we brought it to the film
festival you know
it was kind of a you know very festive
and uh
you know we worked a long time on this
film so when we
you know were there in competition it
was like a real end we were shooting
you know we had the band everybody was
there it was like really a
um was going to be a good time kind of
movie a documentary
you did and we left berlin
and and and we played actually will
played with two
in a packed house we didn't even know
from masks bro
this was february 24th and we got back
to the editing room here
in rome you know we're in the middle of
the night now
and sporting life the documentary became
you know i mean we have all the berlin
film festival in there and all that
you know and it's crazy to see it you
know just
you know three months later in the
editing room when me asking a cruise
should we
stop and have coffee it's like are you
kidding
you know hugging people kissing you know
our normal
behavior seems so just being in that
club that night
so you know we had a chance to uh and
now
the pump coming in the states after the
pandemic a film like that you know
it's it's it's crazy it's a lot to think
about
um kind of doubling back to willem
playing multiple
versions of himself my favorite sequence
in the film
is when he plays this kind of dad
character
yeah please just follow me yeah that
beautiful monologue
the mentioning of like hawaiian punch
and fishing
it felt so specific to me and i'm
curious where
where did that come from was that like
cathartic you know i mean
his father your father yeah you know his
father you know
and um you know and like if you're gonna
pull i mean who's gonna play his father
better than him you know
so you know it's like why not you know
so so we did that in a couple of cases
there
but no that's that's you know he's
channeling
you know it's a memory and you know
as much as a vision you know yeah
what were some of the other instances
where he brought his personal life to uh
to what he was playing well the script
was based a lot on his personal life you
know
i mean we did it was like at least a
starting point
you know we did a film before that
tommaso which was more or less based on
my
day-to-day life in rome you know and
then but then you know when he comes in
then it
you know it's not it's not me anymore
you know and then when we put the camera
on it would you know it just gives us a
starting place
you know very specific starting place
and i was also thinking
you know we've done passolini you know
done movies where he's played
you know real people say passolini where
he played van gogh for julian you know
okay where he plays a character say
that's real
or we create a character like this
you know the dude from go go uh what was
his name oh ray ruby from google tales
you know to us is real because we're so
we know who he's playing but it's a
fictional character
you know i was thinking it would if it's
willem
i mean the inner life of that character
is willem
you did so the character is playing
willem not william trying to play the
character
i mean you know i don't want to get too
spacey on this but
anyway it gives us a place to start you
know
you know what i mean it begins our
journey in a place like okay we know
this now
we know we're gonna go into movie land
you know we're going to do
what we do and we're going to didn't let
the process play out
and in the end it's going to be a movie
you know i don't look at
tommaso and think of myself in fact when
i watch these movies i don't even think
of willem you know i always see tomorrow
so
i mean you know this is willem's gift i
could look at that movie and i'm not
thinking of
the guy who lives next door to me
you know i'm not thinking i never think
i'm thinking who's this
you know poor mixed up crazy [ __ ]
person coming through all this
you know torture you know i hope he
comes
out i hope he lands on his feet at the
end
[Laughter]
i think we we watch it and hope that too
um yeah
let's touch on i want to touch on
passolini a little bit which is a movie
i love
um what yeah what prompted you to make
or want to make a movie about this
filmmaker pasolini do you see
you and him as kind of kindred
artistic spirits or is it something a
little simpler than that
well kindred i mean you know he's like
the teacher and we're the students you
know i mean i grew up with him
and he's like you know one of our
masters you know one of
our you know as a as a as a movie
director
as a man you know as uh you know
everything about him was like you know
we're very young we were like
crazed about them you know but even as i
got
the older we got even the more i got
into it the more and you know william
has the same feelings
the more we felt um i felt
i feel connected to him you know the the
more powerful
his presence and his work is to me
so there was the opportunity it came you
know i don't know where these
he came back a long time somebody
brought up the idea
it seemed i don't know
but we never let it go
it was always an idea we might do and it
was kind of from a produced specific
producer named
augusto caminito he uh he was the
producer of king in new york also a very
cool laid-back guy so it wasn't pushing
me on it or whatever
anyhow willow looks just like the guy
yeah that matters but
it helps and then we're in rome you know
and
um it just it all came together you know
like that
yeah do you remember the first time
you watched a solo or 120 days of sodom
how did that like what did that you know
man we went to the movie theater you
know it was gonna be four hours you know
it was on uh i think 57th street you
know we were waiting for the movie we
went to the first show
it was like 15 people in that you know
bringing wine
and [ __ ] cheese you know we're in
there for the long haul we waited
for the movie you know it was already
dead at that time
um i think yeah for sure and then
um there was like 15 people in that
movie theater
and when it was over it was eight
you didn't i walked at it i walked out
of that theater and the eight of us
we were strangers to each other yeah i
mean people i was with
and we're looking at each other and
everybody knew you know
it was yeah you know it was one of those
experiences you would like
i didn't even know what [ __ ] city it
was in we went in the daytime came out
it
came out it was snowing i think i mean
it was just like i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was
you know yeah i you know it was like
that's
how you want to make somebody feel when
they
watch a movie you know
absolutely where were you where were you
where did you see
boy i saw it for the first time uh
in my basement in detroit michigan
growing up
as like a young budding cinephile and it
uh
[ __ ] rocked my words that's good
that's a good description
you mentioned 57th street new york what
do you think has kind of
over the years i i've noticed in your
career a shift from these kind of
like hard-boiled new york movies to
these more
uh exploratory italian european films
what do you think has prompted them
living here is number one you know you
i'm i don't say i'm older but i'm way
older
um you know it's a journey one movie
takes you to the next
and you know you're open to it and you
know as your life changes as
your experience change the place you
live changes
you know the world around changes and
you just you're open and
to wherever it takes you you know
that makes sense um i
i think it's your your first film the
driller killer
um is a movie i think is i i really like
that movie a lot and i really like your
performance
in it and i'm curious
i'm curious what uh what prompted you to
be in that film
and have you ever thought of like being
the title character in a movie of yours
since
yeah my acting days i think
you know i'm asked to act a lot you
wouldn't believe it but i
you know little bits here and there and
you know i hate to say no to
like young filmmakers but you know i'm
[ __ ] i'm terrible lately i can't even
i can't remember [ __ ] live but um
you know back then it was i didn't
i offered that role to a few people you
know
and um david johansen
you know he is new york dolls yeah yeah
yeah
okay that's one but i you know i was
thinking of other people
and then i started realizing you know
when then i got turned down by the book
then i'm starting realizing you know we
were making that film in the beginning
on weekends
like we'd shoot a weekend pull it
together maybe three
three weeks later we'd shoot again you
know i
i realized how we were gonna have to do
that film and i also realized we needed
to come up with a feature like film so
i thought we might be doing this for the
next two three years so
i just didn't want to risk it you think
i didn't want to
have to you know worry that somebody
that you know you follow what i'm saying
if you're in it you're not going to bail
on it
yeah exactly i mean at least i know i'm
there i knew the dp i could count on him
he was there
and what else you [ __ ] need you know
basically
you know when it gets down to to the
trip i knew the sound guy was going to
be there so
and um i didn't at that time know any
actors that i could count on
you know it was basically a documentary
of a friend of mine that i was living
with at the time
he was a painter and you know something
like the passolini well william you know
we had passelini
william put on his clothes we went to
the place where it happened
you know i mean that loft was my
friend's loft
put his clothes on i knew how he painted
i was watching thank you
yeah you know forever so what was his
reaction when he saw the movie
he's in it oh he's the guitar player
he's the crazy yeah he's the guy who
painted that buffalo and did those
paintings and that's his girlfriend
that's his loft that makes a lot of
sense um
jumping ahead a little bit uh my
favorite film of yours at least today is
china girl i love that movie and i'm
curious why why why why do i love it
yeah i really liked how
the emotional love story was kind of at
the center of it i thought that gave you
a lot of room
it gave a lot of the like the style and
the kind of
hard boiledness of it a nice foundation
which i
i thought made it kind of like really
yeah
yeah uh where does that rank in in your
sort of
opinions you know teenage lovers you
know teenage little bits
yeah that's a powerful [ __ ]
horse um what shiny girl
yeah yeah i you know i'm uh i'm fond of
it you know i have a lot of memories
from
whence when i do see it you know it was
the first time me and boyan worked
together
[Music]
it was you know shot in the street right
there
you know you know you know downtown
manhattan we
chinatown the kids were real
it was it was a good it was a good time
in our lives
i'm curious uh what is exciting you
right now about the film
zeros and ones with ethan hawk what's
what what's exciting about that for you
we don't you know that it's finished
we're gonna play we're gonna
we're gonna you know it's coming to
lucarno it's gonna be
you know lionsgate is also distributing
that
um you know you know you're always
jazzed
jazzed about the new film you know so
i'm like um you know i'm curious to go
see what happens
in lucarno and uh you know i'm
you know ready to lightly and then what
do they say
drop it you know yeah you're ready
to drop your new single yeah drop on a
new joint on the world
let's you know the focus though is
siberia next friday right
so i'm like you know that's like kind of
uh you're playing in the states it's
cool
it's very cool yeah thank you so much
for your time i love the movie and it
was great chat
thank you bro yeah thanks man take care